wilson roosevelt german worked as a
butler at the white house he served
under 11 presidents he made generations
of first families feel at home said
Hillary Clinton including powers German
retired in 2012 after serving as maitre
d to president and mrs. Obama this
picture appears in becoming the
best-selling memoir by Michelle Obama
who said in a statement his willingness
to go above and beyond for the country
he loved and all those whose lives he
touched is a legacy worthy of his
generous spirit Wilson Roosevelt German
was 91 michael halkias owned an opulent
catering Hall in Brooklyn New York
and became famous for long-running
commercials he started with his wife
Alice we made your dreams come true that
guy and prosper halt the ads were
spoofed by Jimmy Kimmel and SNL halkias
met Alice while managing a travel agency
in 1966 married in 1967 they were also
lifelong business partners they bought
the derelict hall in 1981 and spent two
years renovating it halkias loved Greek
culture and his family I was the most
fortunate wife I could be said Alice he
always told me several times a day that
he loved me
Michael halkias was 82
Lisa dawn Robinson was a Philadelphia
percussionist nicknamed Lady rhythm
Robinson toured with pink and played
drums behind soul singer Billy Paul for
more than a decade he loved the way she
played for him said Paul's widow
Blanche Williams they were tailor-made
for each other
Robinson's father was a guitarist with
Harold Melvin and the blue notes as a
toddler she started banging on things
said her sister dr. Pamela chambers to
me she was my little diamond in 2012 a
massive stroke left Robinson paralyzed
on her left side but she worked hard to
become independent again she was very
determined to just live life to the best
of the hand that was dealt her said
longtime friends singer Shirley lights
she just never gave up Lisa dawn
Robinson was 55 Yasmin Pena was a high
school senior at Waterbury arts magnet
school in Connecticut
she loved to draw dance and sing yahzee
as she was called wanted to study
fashion in college she had everything
going for her said her sister Madeline
so much potential and to have it ripped
away it's just mind-boggling Yasmin Pena
was 18
pastor Kendall Pierre senior preached at
Mount Zion Baptist Church in a me Louise
II Anna love you all the more
he was also basketball coach for the
Southeast Louisiana Warriors and ran a
barber shop whereas his wife Sabrina
said a lot of people got a lot of free
counseling sitting in that barber's
chair Kendall and Sabrina met working at
McDonald's married in 1996 and raised
three kids my husband was awesome
Sabrina said he was everything when the
coronavirus hit he taught Bible study by
video it was Sabrina a registered nurse
who later took her husband to the
hospital more than 800 cars attended the
drive-thru wake at Mount Zion
god bless till we meet again
pastor Kendall Rene Pierre senior was 45
you